So we've been talking about all these
different ways to monetize your app
from premium to freemium options.
But sometimes it can be difficult
to decide on a strategy.
Wouldn't it be nice to get paid just
based on how much people liked your
game?
>> Yep, and Amazon has actually
created a monetization model
that tries to do just this.
It's called Amazon Underground.
>> Cool, tell me more about it.
How can a game make
money off of likability?
>> Well,
it's hard to measure likability.
But we can get an idea of that based
on how often a game is played.
So Amazon Underground
pays game developers
based on how much time
players spend in their game.
>> That sounds pretty interesting.
So every player would help
to monetize their game.
>> Exactly.
Amazon Underground has a great
selection of premium apps and games for
free and
all in-app purchases are free, too.
For example, you mentioned
playing Fruit Ninja before.
And in the Underground version,
you can get all the stars and
golden apples you want for free.
They are still packaged in a store,
like in the original game fomat.
But their price is zero.
>> So
no other monetization models are used.
That sounds really easy.
But how much money can a developer
expect to make off of this model?
>> Well, Underground has a per minute
payment rate which translates to
12 cents an hour.
This can add up,
especially if you have a lot of players.
>> What an interesting way to monetize.
This is something to keep in mind
when you're designing your game.
Different platforms may have
built-in monetization strategies.